[Música]
muy buenos días pero siempre que estás
hecho en tierra o bien pues estás hecho
de este mes
y a eso se considera que la estructura
atómica que nos compone a mis ojos fue
conseguirán en el número de estrellas
como producto de sus pueblos que
aparecieron hace miles en 13 años
también creemos saber hasta la fecha que
los cometas depositadas en la superficie
de la tierra en elementos primordiales
desarrollados
entonces no es tan descabellado decir
que todos somos un poco suaves y también
un poco cometes miopes alternadores soy
maestra nacional por la universidad y
mencionó mis credenciales convencidos de
que esta conversación testículo su
naturalidad y relevantes y no
determinantes para retornar los cambios
que queremos ver
de jóvenes
[Música]
algunos estábamos a punto de egresar
están impulsando la mitad de sus
carreras
nos hicimos una pregunta que es lidiar
con los invito que ustedes de la
responda
si tuvieras que hacer seguramente ya
después seguramente ya han visto un
problema que ustedes quisiera resolver
en comunidad en su ciudad en su palacio
en el mundo la respuesta la tienen
ustedes les interesan mismos los
problemas que tenemos que resolver
nosotros al responder esta pregunta
encontramos la razón para fundar una
asociación civil la respuesta que
nosotros vivimos a esta pregunta fue
fomentar un nuevo modelo de ciudadano
que sea más humana solidaria y sobre
todo muy importante con responsable en
generar las soluciones a las
problemáticas que me hagan creer
ciudadanas aguanto vedados proactivos
son necesarias las soluciones no vienen
por parte del gobierno vienen por parte
de la sociedad civil organizada sin
embargo también sea verdad esta pregunta
y es tan gris si tuviera
siendo nosotros jóvenes intentos con
ganas de cambiar nuestra realidad lo
realmente difícil es definir cómo
podemos cambiar
para nosotros significó y significa
resolver en el suelo tres grandes
problemas para fundar una asociación el
primero de los problemas puede pedir de
qué manera vamos a trabajar
ningún trabajo social con asociaciones
que tiene 25 años decidió ir a la
universidad
entonces con este tipo con esta poca
experiencia académica y técnica como
podríamos cambiar el mundo
afortunadamente llegó a nosotros como
epifanía la verán extrapolar y con el
sector desde la empresarial al arte de
la acción social han escuchado planes de
austin no están simplemente el concepto
de subcontratación imaginen que una
empresa de granada de gran tamaño
contratar la empresa más pequeña para
que esta especie contrate empleadas los
empleados para la expresión una vez
celebrada la pequeña crecer su
contratante se desplaza a su siguiente
proyecto parecía que es navegar lo que
nosotros hicimos pues tomar estos
conceptos y agregarlos a nuestra
asociación civil decidimos entonces
entonces débil cargas a diseñar ellos
para asociaciones civiles más grandes y
ya establecidas porque porque estas
asociaciones nos ha ayudado a nets en
primer lugar la infraestructura
y en segundo lugar ya captar a la
población objetivo es un juego de
nuestra nación toma asociaciones
decidimos nosotros entonces ser
intermediadas entre la sociedad civil y
su tablero y las organizaciones grandes
apoyarán a la sociedad
recuerden que tenemos recuerdos fuimos
socios fundadores estudiantes
universitarios todavía si nada más y mis
manuel palacio en el campo entonces se
nos ocurrió recurrir nuevamente a la
sociedad si se nos ocurrió llevar la
mano y crear la red de expertos una
diabetes que es una red de voluntarios
de jóvenes y profesionistas que egresan
a vivir en esas pequeñas infinitas hace
tiene curiosidad por aportar su
conocimiento
pero se les permite a los altos
convocada la sesión listas y que en la
medida de sus posibilidades en los
tiempos que tengan niveles diseñarán
ayer los ejecutivos profesionales y de
excelencia
cuando ustedes no quisiera ver el camino
sí
nosotros somos únicamente un punto donde
convergen todas estas medidas que
quieren carmen es decir la gente no
puede dedicar el cien por ciento de su
tiempo a transformar la realidad pero si
pueden dedicar dos horas
si puedes dedicarle unas dos horas en su
respectivo reconocimiento
a la verde expertos nos dedicamos a cómo
formar latente porque tal es la red de
voluntarios son esos jóvenes que van
equipados cuya crítica diseño las
revistas los jóvenes de esos buscar sus
jóvenes de selección últimos en este de
preparatoria pues es primer semestre es
de universidad que forma enemigos nuevos
niveles de mañana
es crear oportunidades para que puedan
desarrollar y satisfacen sus necesidades
de por activismo social ellos van a ser
la generación que vive actualmente misma
de regresar
fue así como conformamos dos veces sin
querer conformamos un círculo virtuoso
donde nos acercan dos universidades y
preparatorias prácticas jóvenes para
ejecutar los programas en diseñar con
expertos
agregame con estos programas escriben a
organizaciones civiles más generales
todo esto de manera 100%
sin ningún costo
como nosotros somos una organización
universal
[Música]
la asociación civil nosotros diseñamos
los proyectos los micros en la mañana
nuestras sillas puestas nosotros
proyectamos nuestros proyectos en
plataformas virtuales nos comunicamos
por whatsapp de la dirección para
solicitar un registro a la secretaria de
formación
fue maravilloso para nosotros porque
nosotros necesitamos un edificio donde
trabajando nosotros somos una asociación
es decir que el padre de nuestros
recursos como inversión social es
transposición de cada uno de los
miembros de nuestra asociación de cada
uno de los voluntarios voy a adaptar lo
mismo recuerda puede adoptar la gasolina
para trasladarse a cómo vamos a trabajar
puede aportar las rumbas
en realidad tres kilos de los que vamos
a llevarlo a siete nosotros trabajamos
con donaciones las naciones de los
voluntarios también hablamos como todo
tipo de fuente y es el resto de la
sociedad cuando visitamos proyecto
ejecutivo diseñamos una lista de
materiales y recursos necesarios lo
único que tenemos que hacer es levantar
la mano en las redes sociales y comenzar
a salir al pueblo al principio vamos a
apoyar a nuestros fans con nosotros
después con nuestros amigos después con
los amigos de los amigos y eventualmente
los desconocidos así de fácil y así les
sirve y la manera que tenemos apoyo es
por medio de las instituciones a las que
nosotros ayudamos porque porque esas
instituciones ya tienen infraestructura
que nosotros podemos aprovechar para
ejecutar los programas los programas que
les diseñamos están específicamente
considerados para esas instituciones por
lo tanto podemos disponer de sus mesas
de sus sillas pizarrones tenemos
importantes de sus mangas
nosotros nosotros que debe ser una
asociación independiente que debe ser
una asociación que pueda trabajar con
cualquier preso lo que debe es generar
espacios para que cada uno de ustedes
cada enemigo pueda compartir su alegría
pueda compartir sus motivaciones y pueda
compartir su experiencia para tener un
impacto la mayoría de los voluntarios o
simplemente de semana nosotros vamos a
cosechar
me permiten de retomar la introducción
se preguntarán qué tenemos en común los
soles y los corrientes
con nosotros los seres humanos pues bien
los cometas no son sino el principio
rocas cubiertas de hielo y polvo que
viajan con el sistema pero cuando un
cometa cuando hablan estas propias
atracción suficiencia una estrella el
calor de la estrella que los gases en
general
entonces intención es correcta cuando
están suficientemente cerca de la
estrella en las relaciones humanas y en
alguien que está muy diferente educación
es tenemos la doctrina en ese momento y
de poder ser inspirados por otras
personas
y en otras ocasiones como ésta tenemos
el privilegio y la responsabilidad de
ayudar a otros a construir las mejores
canciones de sí mismos
todos somos seres y momentos el lema de
nuestra asociación es inspirar mejorar
mientras cierto este viajero a respirar
a cantidades comienza en sus propios
proyectos la sanción para los canes
generar colectivos generar una
asociación no es fácil los pasos que
deben recibir no son fáciles la única
solución que existe tiene desde esta
creatividad y el potencial y nuestro
apoyo para crear e imaginar la solución
porque sólo así vamos a poder vincular a
esta sociedad vamos a poder decorar con
los seres humanos bien igual que
probablemente trascender desde la
tormenta gracias